fury on the streets of sudan
outside the military headquarters in
khartoum tens of thousands of men and
women are converging once again to show
their anger against a sudden military
takeover that's threatening the nation's
fragile democratic transition
[Applause]
an urgent call to all sudanese civilians
who want to protect the revolution what
the military is doing is a betrayal to
all citizens on all fronts
it is the duty of all civilians to move
and to block all roads outside to
prevent any military force to move
right now all of us must unite to show
the truth
the return of the old regime is
impossible no matter what the excuses or
the justifications the return is
impossible this is the first statement
of the people women and men are refusing
any kind of fraud on democracy and civil
society after months of power struggle
sudan's generals arrested several
civilian members of the governing
sovereign council and moved prime
minister abdullah
to an undisclosed location
the internet and phone lines are
disrupted and the airport in karthum
closed
the pro-democracy coalition born out of
the 2019 uprising that ousted long-time
leader omar al-bashir has called for
protests and strikes to resist what it
thinks is a military coup
last month a failed coup attempt by
forces loyal to bashir widen divisions
between the military and civilian sides
of the transitional government
both sides blame each other for slow
reforms a worsening economic crisis
poverty and corruption the deal that was
signed in august of 2019 was always
flawed in a number of ways
for me two of the biggest flaws were
that the
military were going to maintain control
of gold mines and other
financial interests sort of independent
of the state and in a somewhat corrupt
manner and that they were never really
going to investigate themselves enough
for the massacres of june 2019.
the hard-won gains of the pro-democracy
uprising have not led to reforms many
people fought for
and now with more political upheaval
sudan is once again on the edge priyanka
gupta al-jazeera
well this is what we know so far about
who's been arrested most members of
sudan's civilian leadership including
members of the transitional sovereignty
council have been detained by the
military as we mentioned earlier prime
minister abdullah has been taken to an
unknown location according to the
culture and information ministry his
media adviser faisal muhammad salla has
been detained so has mohammed al-fakhi
suleiman he's the spokesman for the
sovereign council and has been vocally
criticizing the military and the
ministry the minister of industry
ibrahim al-shaikh and the minister of
information hamza balul have also been
placed under arrest according to reports
let's go live then to sudan's capital
khartoum al jazeera's heber morgan is uh
on the line now heber morgan uh
we're going to interrupt you in a moment
because we're expecting a statement
in fact we're going to that statement
right now let's listen
who doesn't believe in peace and justice
that's why when the december
revolutionaries
say their slogans and thousands of them
stood in front of the general command of
the armed forces the armed forces
responded positively and decided to work
to achieve the aspiration of the people
to achieve the aspiration of the nation
justice
peace and freedom because we are quite
convinced that the sudanese people
deserve
a nation a nation that they can practice
and see
these slogans and these big names in the
nation until the moment we deliver power
to a
civilian government that will achieve
more
during this transitional period
the armed forces were quite aware and
the people
were quite aware
of the partnership between the military
people and the civilians to go through
the same way in order to achieve the
goals of the people through general
elections
through
the practices that we have been
doing and witnessing all over a year
and this will include the leaders and
the powers because other than that
there will be divisions that is that are
a threat to the safety of
our nation
prime minister abdullah
has seen that in his initiative in july
and october
of this year
so the armed forces
because it's the constituent power of
this transitional period
the armed forces has a national duty to
keep and the safety and sovereignty of
the nation according to
the constitutional draft and according
to the mission of the armed foe says
that's why we need not
to distract the nation and we need not
to destroy the nation we have started
our path towards the states of freedom
justice and peace but some political
powers are still trying
to maintain everything in their hands
without paying attention to the threats
political threats and economic threats
and social threats
that's why in the armed forces and the
rapid support forces we were keen to
take the necessary steps that will keep
and maintain
the december revolution until we reach
the final goal which is a civil state
via
fair and just elections that's why we
decided the following to declare a state
of emergency
nationwide
to adhere and to commit ourselves to
what has been mentioned in the
constitutional document
and the agreement of peace in sudan
signed in juba in october 2020
three
do we suspend
the oppression of article 11
12
15 and 16
23 24 3 71 72
of the constitutional
draft
and we commit ourselves to all the
agreements signed by
us
we
dissolve the sovereign council
and the cabinet
and
we
put an end to the job of the mayors
and the under secretaries
and the
the
department
and the general department in the states
will
do their job and we will revise
everything
and we will take
decisions towards everything
and we urge everyone to abide by
the agreement of juba 2020 we stress
and we confirm
that some
of our people in the east have their own
sufferings and we are quite sure
that justice and peace must prevail
so we need to work hard in order to
reach
last solutions
that will meet the aspirations of our
people and that would sort out the
problems nationwide we believe that the
december revolution is going on because
the people who have started this
revolution
believe in the golden aims and goals of
the revolution
and we all
starting from today
till the date of the elections in july
2023 we urge everyone to work hard
to pave the way for better living to
create a better environment for the
parties to work hard until the date of
the elections we need everyone to be
ready to lead the country after the
elections
a government of independent
people will be formed after elections to
represent all the people of the sudan we
will be keen
to apply every rule of justice
and we will support
the judiciary the constitutional court
the
all the
cornerstones that will help our nation
to
be solid and strong
revolutionary parliament will be also
created to monitor the situation
and to monitor the steps being taken for
the welfare of the sudanese people we
need to work hard we need to produce
because our people and our nation
deserves all sacrifices we need to keep
our country and we need to keep our
people safe we are quite committed to
the items
of the
constitutional agreement and the juba
agreement and we urge abdullah aziz
we urge abdullah muhammad
to join the path of building the new
sedan
sudan where freedom justice will prepare
because
no group or no individual will impose
their opinion again
on sudanese people we thank iran and we
thank the friends of sudan because their
ongoing support in order to make this
transition period a success a big salute
to our great people of sudan for the
sake of the country and for the sake of
the nation
i would like to thank
members
of the armed forces and the rapid
support forces who are doing the best
may allah bestow his mercy on our
martyrs
and allah almighty will do
what allah almighty wants and peace be
upon you all all right that
was abdul fattah al-buhan the sovereign
council chairman speaking on sudanese tv
he said that the military in sudan has
acted to achieve the aspirations of the
people he's declared a state of
emergency across the country
he has
said that he's going to remove
state governors he's dissolving the
sovereign council and the government
he says what the country is going
through threatens its security and
future he says that uh a struggle uh
that was going on politically threatened
sudan's peace and stability he says that
the balanced agreement had had turned uh
into a struggle between
transition partners
and that the military council will
continue with democrat the democratic
transition
until
a handover to a civilian elected
government and he said that elections
would take place in july 2023
let's bring in al jazeera's hippo morgan
who's out on the streets in khartoum i
don't know how much of uh of that you
heard heber what are we to make of it
well i've heard pretty much all adrian
and
one thing we do know is that the
constitutional declaration that the
power sharing document that was signed
between the forces of freedom and change
coalition and the translational military
council which overturned senate
president omarosa is no more that is one
thing that we can conclude from the
statement of uh
now this is anything because it's
constitutes uh after exactly that
constitutional declaration uh that
responded to the site any going against
any article of that document is a clue
and this is what we uh what people here
on the streets are seeing some of them
as they're walking by past the
presidential palace uh have been
chanting uh civilian governments they've
been chanting against
them many foreign them making their way
to the army headquarters and you can see
the radios were turned down they're
listening to that statement and reacting
that they're reacting to this minute by
minutes
you could see the anger you can see the
frustration that many of them seem to be
determined that they don't want
president abdul and
to be the one to leave them until
elections are held after the new day
that he announced in july 2023 so we're
seeing hundreds and hundreds of people
walking past the presidential palace
chanting against happiness and gohan and
against the military saying that they
wanted iranian government but now it
looks like that constitutional
declaration that was set to bring them
that uh civilian government that they've
been looking for is out of the window
i'm gonna buy this argument that the
military acted in their interests
well again we've been talking to
professors not just over the past week
uh the importance in front of the
presidential palace where this is taking
decision as well as protesters who
turned out on thursday to commemorate
the anniversary of the first revolution
against the military rule now they say
that uh the only thing that is in their
interest is having noble politicians
these are the protesters who are outside
the uh uh on the streets of harper but
those in front of the presidential pilot
have been calling for the military to
dissolve the cabinet and form a new
government so whether it's in the
interest of the civilians or of the
people as
president
although the people would accept that um
that excuse that he's given for
dissolving the sovereignty council and
the cabinet did that remain but we're
already seeing people reacting to this
statement saying that they don't think
that um
that he is actually doing this because
he cares for the nation let's not forget
that for weeks now political parties
have been accusing azerbaijan
and his victory of wanting to grab power
and not being keen to hand it over to
civilian rule which coincidentally
should happen next month after the
forces of freedom and change coalition
according to the egypt peace agreement
and the constitution declaration
so it looks like the fact that um
the military supposed to handle the
power of civilians has triggered this uh
the overthrow of the constitutional
declaration of decline between the two
sides
al jazeera's hibern live in khartoum
hibbert we'll be back with you a little
later uh so how did sudan get to this
point well in december 2018 thousands of
people in the northeastern region of
barra protested against high
unemployment poverty and corruption
within days those protests spread to
other cities including the capital
khartoum in april 2019 the military
removed president omar al-bashir from
office after nearly 30 years in power
four months later and after accusations
of use of violence against protesters
the military agreed to form a
civilian-led transitional government now
this new cabinet took office in
september under prime minister abdullah
as part of a three-year power sharing
agreement let's bring in jonas horner
who's in nairobi he's the deputy
director for the horn of africa and
senior analyst for sudan with the
international crisis group
jonas what did you make of that
statement there from the sovereign
council chairman
i thought it was remarkably disingenuous
and self-serving actually um you know
the claim that the december
revolutionary revolution is ongoing um
is is going to raise a lot of hackles in
the streets with those who have come out
to really protest this this coup uh i
think it's particularly disingenuous
given that the military have been key to
creating the conditions for this discord
and security um and certainly in
congress too given that um berhana's you
know in many ways ostensibly head of
state in this uh hybrid transitional
arrangement um and those who have been
part of this this movement to push the
government out are themselves key
members of government so any criticism
of government performance is very much
self-criticism and uh
and then again seems incredibly
disingenuous and incongruous as a result
um i think though ultimately um you know
our sense of christ group of what burhan
and the military and others around him
are seeking uh holds out and was borne
out by the speech which is to say
the hope is for a more friendly a
civilian government that will protect
the interests of the military and other
old guard groups who who will come to
see themselves who do believe they will
become losers uh in sudan under the um
under a democratic transition as as laid
out in the country's constitutional
declaration is that what he was alluding
to when he was saying that there are
political powers trying to hold
everything in their hands without being
aware of the threats
yes well uh you know
again these divisions are are being
manufactured uh they are to be fair
divisions that have existed throughout
the two years of this transition so you
know in many ways the actual um division
lines aren't particularly surprising
it's much more that they've come out in
the open so so so suddenly so readily
after a previous coup attempt almost one
month ago um and and in many ways the
hope has been that we could manage those
inherent um differences of opinion
differences in hope about what you know
the very sort of nature and future of
sudan might be in a more a cool and less
violent and less uh less intense way but
today's this morning's events really um
you know throw a spanner in those works
um you know we still really like to to
see um the military uh you know given a
sense that there is some place for them
ultimately at the table um you know in a
civilian dispensation um
and there's also a real need to speak to
some of the regional actors who have
been instrumental in empowering the
military to be much more uh let's say
aggressive in these recent weeks he said
the final goal is still free and fair
elections and a handover to a civilian
government elections are going to be
held in july 2023 should we believe him
i think uh
we might be able to believe him there is
some tactical and strategic um
preference i would say on on the side of
the military and the old guard political
parties to have elections sooner rather
than later because this allows what this
you know forestalls any of the new
political forces from getting a toehold
um in the the you know chaotic political
milieu uh in in sudan and so those who
exist those who have existing uh
structures to mobilize supporters to get
them to the polls they you know would
appear to have an inherent advantage so
in many ways
for the old guard quicker elections are
perhaps preferable
how do you see this playing out now as
far as um people on the streets uh are
concerned uh jonas as our correspondent
was saying a few moments ago it's clear
that the people people don't buy into to
his argument that the military was
acting to achieve the aspirations of the
people
yes no i think that those those
aspirations are diametrically opposed um
you know just uh on the 21st of this
month and there were
major protests that saw people come out
into the street requesting you know this
the exact opposite of what rohan seems
to be uh believing he is fulfilling on
behalf of people you know people come
out
in great numbers countrywide to request
that uh the civilians be remain the
central component to this transition and
that the military you know end their
disruptive approach to this um so you
know yeah
they're they're mutually exclusive and
and i think those on the streets now
will be you know really furious about
berhan's uh instrumentalizing of the
freedom peace and justice uh slogan for
example john it's really good to talk to
you many thanks indeed for being with us
jonas horner there in nairobi